hallo zusammen und Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live schön dass ihr bei uns seid
es gibt eine neue Entwicklung im Fall
nordstream Schweden steigt aus den
Ermittlungen aus wir erinnern uns Ende
September
2022 beschädigen mehrere Explosionen auf
dem Grund der ostse die Pipelines
nordstream 1 und 2 die lex befinden sich
in internationalen Gewässern zwei von in
der Wirtschaftszone Dänemarks zwei in
Schweden die Pipelines sind zum
Zeitpunkt der Explosionen nicht in
Betrieb enthalten aber jede Menge Gas
welches tagelang an die Oberfläche der
Ostsee aufsteigt es gilt als gesichert
dass es sich bei den Explosionen um
vorsätzliche Sprengungen handelt aber
wer dahinter steckt ist bis heute nicht
final
geklärt hier stellt sich die Frage ob
jetzt Deutschland den Fall lösen kann
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit Christian
Rode vom ZDF investigativmagazin frontal
Christian koordiniert im ZDF
investigative Recherchen und in einem
Team mit Journalisten und
Journalistinnen der Redaktion frontal
und dem Nachrichtenmagazin Der Spiegel
hat er zum Fall nordstream recherchiert
wir sprechen dann mit unserem
Korrespondenten in Brüssel gon Krüger
und werden ihn fragen wie EU und NATO
reagiert haben um weitere Attacken
dieser Art zu verhindern und wir haben
raapael B von der STI Wissenschaft und
Politik zu Gast er forscht dazu wie
maritime kritische Infrastruktur
generell geschützt werden kann wir sind
gespannt auf eure Fragen und auf eure
Kommentare einfach in die Chats
schreiben oder schickt uns eine mail ich
gebe das alles gerne weiter jetzt
starten wir mit Christian Rode von
Frontal hallo Christian hallo Christian
fangen wir vielleicht mal ganz von vorne
an mit der Frage warum steigt Schweden
denn aus den Ermittlungen aus ja die
Nachricht heute war ja erstmal
erstaunlich auf den ersten Blick
schließlich liegen ja die Tatorte in den
Gewässern nahe Schwedens zwei gaslex
wurden Nähe Dänemark bornhnholm gefunden
zwei andere gaslex liegen in diesen
Wirtschaftszonen besonderen
Wirtschaftszonen von Schweden also denkt
man erstmal warum steigen die aus der
Ermittlung aus auf den zweiten Blick
sieht es dann doch ein bisschen anders
aus der Staatsanwalt erklärte heute es
sind keine schwedischen Staatsbürger
beteiligt und let ist der Anschlag auch
kein Anschlag auf die schwedische
Infrastruktur und das ist das Wichtigste
die Ermittlung werden ja jetzt auch
nicht eingestellt sondern die
Ermittlungsergebnisse gibt der
schwedische Staat an die deutschen
Ermittlungsbehörden weiter und deshalb
ist es auch falsch was heute aus Moskau
kommt z.B vom kremmelsprecher Peskow der
sagt nun werde die Sache zu den Akten
gelegt nein das stimmt nicht es wird
weiter
ermittelt aber was bedeutet das jetzt
konkret für die weiteren Ermittlung und
was was ist da überhaupt jetzt gerade
der aktuelle Stand das bedeutet für die
Ermittlung dass sie erstmal weitergehen
und zwar vor allen Dingen in Deutschland
geführt werden es wird auch noch in
Dänemark ermittelt da kam heute die
Meldung dass demnächst auch die dänische
Staatsanwaltschaft sagen wird wo es lang
geht in Polen wird auch nach ermittelt
in Deutschland der Stand ungefähr
folgendermaßen die general
buundesanwaltschaft führt das Verfahren
warum weil sie sagt dass er ein Anschlag
auf die kritische Infrastruktur von
Deutschland gewesen und sie hat
meineschtens handfeste Spuren und diese
Spuren führen vor allen Dingen in die
Ukraine was kann man dazu sagen die
Ermittler sehen das Segelboot diese
Jacht an dromme da als das Tatwerkzeug
an dieses Tatwerkzeug wenn man es so
sagen will haben sie aufwendig überprüft
nämlich schon im Januar 2023 dort haben
sie sprengstoffspuren gefunden
sogenanntes HMX was auch am Tatort
gefunden wurde nämlich an den Röhren
unter Wasser und sie haben Pässe
gefunden von
Mitgliedern dieser Crew und Hinweise
gibt es dann dass diese Pässe Richtung
Ukraine führen auch wenn es sich um
sagen wir mal Pässe handelt die
gefälscht worden sein könnten wir hatten
damals herausgefunden dass eine Spur
sozusagen Richtung Moldawien führt da
waren wir bei einer Person die so ein
Pass hatte den die ukra die Ermittler
gefunden haben da stellte sich dann raus
der Pass wurde nur benutzt und die Spur
führt dann zu einem
valerik der in Social Media Plattformen
Fotos verbreitet hat wo man ihn erkennt
als ukrainischen Soldat das bedeutet
noch nicht dass der Mann das ist aber es
ist zumindest eine handfeste Spur die in
die Ukraine führt und die zweite
wichtige Spur ist die Anmietung der
Andromeda also des Bootes das geschah
aus Warschau und Spuren E-Mails führen
eben in die Ukraine denn es wurde
E-Mailverkehr zwischen Ukraine und war
festgestellt von den Ermittlern deshalb
glauben die deutschen Ermittler es seien
eher Spuren in die Ukraine als anders
wohin und wenn sich das jetzt
bewahrheiten würde dass eben die Ukraine
verantwortlich ist für diesen Anschlag
welche Konsequenz müsste das in
politischer Hinsicht nach sich ziehen
das damit wäre doch die Bundesregierung
auch in einem schwierigen Dilemma der
Bundeskanzler hat ja immer wieder betont
dass Aufklärung das Wichtigste sei und
dass die das Interesse der
Bundesregierung es ist dass die Täter
vor Gericht stell gestellt werden das
Bundeskanzleramt informiert den
Bundeskanzler ständig und stetig über
die Ermittlungen
m es gibt keinen Nachweis bisher dass
sozusagen die Täter die mutmaßlichen
Täter vom ukrainischen Staat gesteuert
worden sind das dementiert die Ukraine
auch massiv
und so kann die Bundesregierung immer
sagen wir sagen gar nichts sondern der
General buundesanwalt soll er Mitteln
und erst wenn er etwas Handfestes hat
wird er anklager erheben das hat er
bisher nicht getan deshalb kann die
Bundesregierung sich auch in Schweigen
hüllen ich glaube aber meine
Einschätzung ist selbst wenn es sich am
Ende herausstellen sollte dass die Täter
aus der Ukraine kommen wird das zwar die
Stimmung im Land gegen die Ukraine nicht
verbessern schließlich unterstützen wir
ja die Ukraine äh massiv mit Geld und
Waffen im Kampf gegen den Angreifer
Russland aber die Bundesregierung so
meine Einschätzung wird niemals von der
Seite der Ukraine weichen äh das ist
glaube ich auch keine Alternative sich
dann auf einmal sozusagen an die
russische Seite zu stellen mm es gibt
einen Kommentar im Chat funaru schreibt
die Geheimdienste Wissen zu 100% was
vorgefallen ist würdest du das Teilen es
gab ja auch Warnungen der Geheimdienste
im Vorfeld ja zu 100%. also das ist eine
starke Behauptung äh wir haben ja in der
Vergangenheit sehr oft erlebt dass die
Geheimdienste ganz schön wenig wussten
wenn man z.B an den Fall der Mauer denkt
oder auch an den Angriffskrieg Russlands
auf die Ukraine wo bis zum Schluss
niemand ganz genau gesagt hat die machen
das oder an den Fall Kabuls in
Afghanistan wo auch alle ziemlich
überrascht waren dass die Taliban äh das
Land überrannt haben richtig ist es gab
Warnungen der holländische oder
niederländische Geheimdienst hat vor dem
Anschlag Wochen vor dem Anschlag äh über
andere Dienste und direkt die
Bundesregierung bzw dort die
verbindungsbehörden informiert dass ein
Anschlag mit einem Boot und zwar
wahrscheinlich von ukrainischen Tätern
geplant ist der Anschlag sollte
stattfinden zu einer natoübung in der
Zeit dann passierte dieser Anschlag
nicht und alle legten sich sich wieder
hin und dachten wird schon nichts
passieren und dann wenige Woche später
explodierten doch die gaspiplants also
was man sagen kann Geheimdienste Wissen
Dinge aber nicht alles es gibt ja auch
die Theorie von einer fals Flag Aktion
also dass Russland in Wahrheit hinter
den Anschlägen steckt und der Ukraine
die Schuld zuschiebt welche Hinweise
gibt es
darauf es gibt zwei Spuren die in
Richtung Russland führen könen
das eine sind massive Schiffsbewegungen
rund um die Tatorte und zwar auch mit
Schiffen die z.B ein miniubo
transportieren könnte konnten mit denen
man dann Richtung
ostegrund tauchen könnte um dort
z.B explosive Fracht anzulegen das ist
das eine und das andere ist die
mehrheitsaktionären der Firma die aus
Warschau die Andromeda angemietet hat
eine dan t ist hat einen ukrainischen
pass aber es gibt von ihr Fotos auf
Social Media Kanälen nach dem Anschlag
die sie in Russland und auf der russisch
besetzten Krim zeigen und das sind die
beiden Spuren wo Politiker vor allen
Dingen Politiker die die Ukraine
unterstützen sagen
seht das ist doch ein klarer Hinweis
dass Russland hinter der Tat steckt
allerdings hat der General Bundesanwalt
Otte äh in geheimer Sitzung oder in
vertraulicher Sitzung mit nchos gesagt
es liegen bisher keine belastbaren oder
handfesten Belege vor dass Russland
hinter den Anstiegen steckt stellt sich
noch die Frage nach Polen welche Rolle
spielt Polen bei den Ermittlungen und
was wird sich da möglicherweise jetzt
ändern mit der neuen Regierung ja die
Rolle Polens ist ein wenig mysteriös
muss man sagen am 19 September 202 das
ist sicher legte die Andromeda also das
mutmaßliche
Tatfahrzeug in Kolberg das ein
polnischer Hafen an der ostseeküfte an
dort ging die Kuh von Bord und wurde von
polnischen Grenzbeamten kontrolliert das
wissen wir wir wissen auch dass die
Pässe angeschaut wurden identifiziert
wurden wir wissen auch weil wir vor Ort
waren dass dieser Hafen voller
Videokameras ist es ist also zu vermuten
dass es eigentlich
Videoaufnahmen von dieser Crew gibt
außer die wurden sofort gelöscht was
kaum vorstellbar ist und die polnischen
Behörden haben damals öffentlich gesagt
nur
eins es waren keine polnischen
Staatsbürger beteiligt und in Kolberg
wurde nichts an Bord geschafft was für
das Attentat in Frage kommt später wurde
bekannt durch Recherchen des Spiegels
dass polnische Dienste an deutsche
Dienste gemeldet hätten dass die Crew
aus russischen Staatsbürgern besteht
damit wurde natürlich wieder der
Verdacht Richtung Russland lenkt in
Berlin und bei den Diensten hier hielt
man diese Äußerung allerdings für wenig
glaubhaft und auch andere Dienste in
anderen Ländern sprachen sogar von
Desinformation der polnischen
Regierung was jetzt mit der neuen
Regierung kommt ist unklar feststeht die
Zusammenarbeit der polnischen und
deutschen Behörden in dieser Sache war
sagen wir mal nicht besonders schön oder
besonders effizient und möglicherweise
lag das an der nicht gerade guten
zusammen Beit der beiden Regierungen in
der Vergangenheit nun kommt eine neue
Regierung und vielleicht kommt da dann
Dynamik rein und es werden neue
Dokumente und neue Tatsachen oder Belege
Richtung Berlin geliefert Christian ich
habe noch eine letzte Frage an dich aus
dem Chat von Rüdiger
er fragt muss man denn jetzt überhaupt
wissen wer das war er meint die Russen
hatten doch schon vorher den han
zugedreht und benutzt wird diese
Pipeline bestimmt nicht mehr ja also
mich interessiert schon wer den größten
Anschlag auf die kritische Infrastruktur
Europas geplant und durchgeführt hat
weil es hat ja dann doch Konsequenzen in
der Frage mit wem arbeitet man zusammen
international wem vertraut man ich
glaube dass es ziemlich wichtig wäre
dass die Bundesregierung wenn Sie mehr
weiß als öffentlich bekannt ist das auch
öffentlich macht denn nur so kann man
verrückten Verschwörungstheorien etwas
entgegensetzen die z.B behaupten Amerika
stecke dahinter äh oder Russland war es
ganz bestimmt oder die Ukraine war es
nicht ich glaube Klarheit und
Transparenz hilft letztlich
allen damit beantwortest du oder
kommentierst du auch den das Statement
von Elias der schreibt die Frage ist do
nicht ob Deutschland den Fall aufklären
kann sondern ob es den Fall aufklären
möchte aus Angst unangenehme
Entdeckungen zu machen er schreibt ohne
inverschwörungstheorien abdriften zu
wollen vielen Dank Christian Rode vom
ZDF Magazin frontal mach gut tschüss
vielen Dank Ciao ja eins zeigt sich die
maritime kritische Infrastruktur und
dazu gehört ja eine Gaspipeline wie
nordstream sind dann doch die sind dann
doch relativ ungeschützt fragen wir nach
bei unserem Korrespondenten Gunner
Krüger in Brüssel hallo Gunna hallo gun
wie überraschend war denn jetzt die
Einstellung des nordstream Verfahrens in
Schweden wie sind die Reaktionen in
Brüssel also das hat hier niemanden
überrascht zumindest nicht bei der NATO
die NATO schwebt in solchen Dingen ein
bisschen über den Dingen man sieht das
ganz eben ganz so wie es eben auch
Christian geschildert hat nicht als eine
Einstellung der Ermittlung sondern
einfach nur als eine kleine Etappe in
Ermittlung die sich schon lange ziehen
und sich noch eine Weile weiter
hinziehen werden also von der NATO heute
keine offizielle Reaktion du
ähm der stam Anschlag Entschuldigung
jetzt hatte ich gerade den Faden
verloren ist ja jetzt eine Weile her das
ist ja schon Ende September
2022 passiert was hat sich den auf
EU-Ebene und bei der NATO seitdem getan
um eben kritische Infrastruktur besser
zu schützen du warst ja auch selbst mit
der Marine in der Ostsee
unterwegs richtig wir waren im letzten
Sommer unterwegs mit einem Minentaucher
einsatzbot dass der Deutschen Bundes der
deutschen Marine im äh im Verbund mit
der NATO aber bevor wir darauf kommen
vielleicht einmal kurz die die
offizielle Antwort bei der NATO auf
solche Attacken auf die kritische
Infrastruktur
die ist seit nordstream auch seit dem
Zwischenfall mit Baltic Connector einem
einer anderen Gaspipeline zwischen
Estland und Finnland die ist immer
dieselbe man hat eigentlich eine
dreifältige Antwort erstens sagt man wir
haben eine politische Antwort die findet
man hier im Hauptquartier in Brüssel da
gibt es seit über einem Jahr eine Stelle
die koordiniert die soll dafür sorgen
dass es eine bessere Koordination gibt
zwischen den Regierungen innerhalb der
natostaaten aber vor allem auch mit der
Industrie also eine bessere Vernetzung
da ist extra ein ehemaliger General aus
Deutschland übrigens abgestellt dafür
und dann gibt es eine rein militärische
Antwort im Marinekommando der NATO gibt
es eine Stelle die die Patrouillen jetzt
besser kontrolliert entlang von
kritischer maritimer Infrastruktur und
dann fördert dritte Antwort die NATO
technische Innovation um eben solche
kritische Infrastruktur besser
überwachen zu können und das ganze hat
einfach nur ein Ziel nämlich ein
besseres Lagebild zu erstellen Lagebild
damit meinen die Militärs dass man zu
jeder Zeit genau weiß wer wo mit welchen
Fähigkeiten an welcher Infrastruktur
unterwegs ist und letztlich liegt das
Ziel darin dieses lagebilds dass man
einfach eine bessere Zuordnung machen
kann dass man genau sagen kann wenn es
irgendwo einen Zwischenfall gegeben hat
dass man das diesen Zwischenfall dass
man die Attacke auch wirklich einem
Urheber zu zuordnen kann und das
wiederum hat ein ganz konkretes Ziel wir
sehen schon seit Jahren in Zuwachs an
maritimer kritischer Infrastruktur
weltweit und deswegen natürlich auch
eine größere
Verwundbarkeit und die Antwort darauf
ist einfach ähm wenn man das schützen
will dann muss man äh wissen wer darüber
unterwegs ist und diese tiefe die ist
auf der einen Seite natürlich ein Schutz
nicht alle können so weit runter und auf
der anderen Seite ist Tiefe manchmal
verlaufen solche Kabel oder Pipelines ja
ein bis zu 5000 m Tiefe
das ist natürlich auch ein Schutz für
jeden Angreifer weil nicht genau klar
ist wer da agiert und wenn das so diffu
bleibt wenn die Bedrohung diffu bleibt
wenn man eben wie auch im Fall
nordstream nicht genau zu ordnen kann
wer ist hier der Urheber dann ist das
Teil von hybrider Kriegsführung dann
kann man nicht genau sagen wer greift
uns da an aber es sorgt für
Verunsicherung gesorgt vielleicht auch
für Zwietracht im Bündnis allein die
Frage wer hier der Urheber ist könnte ja
eben Einfluss haben auf die
Positionierung der NATO in diesem
Konflikt in dem Russland die Ukraine
angegriffen hat also diese ganzen
Überlegungen stecken dahinter warum man
in Zukunft eben mehr wissen will darüber
was über kritischer Mar Thema
Infrastruktur passiert und man muss ja
auch sagen die Sabotage an nordstream
war vielleicht die größte Attacke aber
bei wearten mir auch nicht die
einzige richtig es war nicht die einzige
hier bei der NATO geht man so von drei
vier Zwischenfällen im Jahr aus die
solche Auswirkung haben dass man sich
das auch mal genauer anschaut und
vielleicht zwei Beispiele rausgegriffen
eins davor
das war im Januar
2022 da fehlte auf einmal ein Stück von
einem Datenkabel was Norwegen mit der
Insel Spitzbergen also zwebad verbindet
das bringt das Internet sozusagen nach
nach Spitzbergen und da fehlt da ein
langes Stück Kabel und das zeigt einfach
mal die Dimensionen die es gibt also
Datenkabel umspannen die Welt das ist
natürlich ein ein Netz das besonders
viele Knotenpunkte oder besonders dick
gebündelt ist gerade auf der Achse
zwischen Nordeuropa zwischen
Großbritannien den britischen Inseln und
und Nordamerika und das ist natürlich
auch das Rückrad der NATO und diese
diese Stelle wird als die vulnerabelste
also die die die verletzlichste
angesehen und die muss natürlich auch
besonders geschützt werden wenn man mal
die Gesamtlänge betrachtet man rechnet
von ungefähr 1,34 Millionen Kilometer
Datenkabel rings um die Welt also es
ginge 32 mal um die Welt das kann man
nicht ständig schützen und das zeigt wie
groß die Aufgabe ist und ein anderer
Zwischenfall den haben wir eben schon
angesprochen Baltic Connector das ist
eine Gaspipeline die zwischen Estland
und Finnland verläuft da ist man sich
mittlerweile ziemlich sicher dass es ein
ein Anker eines chinesischen Frachters
war dass der das ausgelöst hat das war
nach den Anschlägen von nordsteam da war
die Aufmerksamkeit auch schon größer
aber das zeigt noch mal etwas anderes
nämlich dass es eine enge Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Militärs und privaten geben
muss also zwischen den Betreib
mit den Betreibern dieser Anlagen denn
die haben die Sensorik die wissen ganz
genau wann es einen Druckabfall gibt und
die haben die Technik entlang der
der der Pipelines sie können in den
Pipelines über den Pipelines Drohnen
durchschicken die inspizieren können das
hat man übrigens auch an zahlreichen
Infrastrukturen zahlreichen Pipelines
gemacht nach den nordstream Pipelines
weil man eben gerade die Befürchtung
hatte dass sich so etwas wiederholen
konnte bislang meistens dann mit einer
Entwarnung und vielleicht um noch mal
zum Schluss die Dimension klar
zumachchen die Ermittlungen unterliegen
ja strengster Geheimhaltung denn es
bleibt ja auch brisant ein Anschlag auf
kritische Infrastruktur könnte ja
theoretisch sogar ein natobündnisfall
auslösen richtig das könnte den Artikel
auslösen und das hat man auch noch mal
von Seiten der NATO in der Doktrin
festgeschrieben das war im Juli 202 hier
in Brüssel da hat man ganz klar Hybride
Angriffe auf kritische Infrastruktur die
auf Territorium von natostaaten oder in
ihren Wirtschaftszonen eben verlaufen
hat man ganz klar festgehalten als einen
möglichen Auslöser für den beistandsfall
aber man muss auch ganz klar festhalten
dieser dieser Artikel 5 das ist kein
rwerk das ausgelöst wird und das dann
automatisch zu zu folgen führt sondern
gerade diese diese Unklarheit wann
Artikel 5 ausgerufen wird und was dann
die Antwort ist Artikel in auf Basis von
Artikel 5 gerade diese Unklarheit ist
auch Teil der Abschreckung der NATO also
Dieu zu sein in diesem Punkt hilft eben
auch den einen möglichen Angreifer in
der unwegbarkeit zu lassen dass er nicht
weiß welche Form von Angriffen
tatsächlich auch zu einem Gegenschlag
führen könnten lieber gun vielen Dank
für deine Einordnung liebe Grüße nach
Brüssel tschüss
g ja am Meeresgrund der Ost und Nordsee
verlaufen viele wichtige Kabel und
Pipelines vielleicht können wir mal kurz
diese Seite hier zeigen genau sie
sichern eben unsere Gas und
Stromversorgung und auch unsere
Telekommunikationsleitungen und
spätestens seit den Anschlägen auf die
Pipelines nordstream 1 und 2 stellt sich
eben die Frage sind diese Verbindungen
sicher wird die kritische Infrastruktur
unter Wasser genügend geschützt einige
Antworten hat Gunner schon gegeben wir
wollen jetzt mit raapael Besson von der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
sprechen erforscht zur strategischen
Bedeutung maritimer kritischer
Infrastruktur und wie diese kritische
Infrastruktur in internationalen
Gewässern geschützt werden kann guten
Abend Herr Buson guten Abend also gunah
Krüger hat ja gerade geschildert was auf
europäischer bzw auf natoebene passiert
nemen deutsch Land und die NATO die
Bedrohung ernst
genug ja also im Diskurs sicherlich und
auch in vielen strategiepapieren ist das
jetzt ganz oben auf
die Frage ist aber natürlich einerseits
was ist davon dann wirklich praktikabel
wir haben ja über die Dimension gerade
geredet und das andere ist natürlich es
gibt auch immer sehr viel
unterschiedliche Anforderungen wo das
Geld die Mittel dann hininvestiert
werden und da muss man dann auch
Prioritäten setzen also wir können
sicherlich nicht versprechen dass jetzt
jetzt alles umfassend geschützt wird und
man muss eben sehen dass auch in den
kommenden Jahren die jetzt erklärten
Ziele und bedrohungswahrnehmung dann
auch hochgehalten werden und umgesetzt
werden denn all das braucht Zeit es gibt
eine Frage aus dem Chat eben lässt sich
kritische Infrastruktur wie Pipelines
oder Datenkabel überhaupt zu 100%
schützen das haben sie gerade schon
beantwortet aber es gibt noch eine
Folgefrage und wenn nein müssen wir dann
mit dem Risiko leben oder was sind die
Schlussfolgerungen
daraus also zum gewissen Grad natürlich
das ist in der Natur der Sache es gibt
unterschiedliche Ansätze wie man damit
umgehen kann das eine ist die berühmt
berüchtigte Resilienz das heißt also
dass man das System so baut dass ein
Ausfall einer Infrastruktur oder eines
bestimmten Punktes nicht dazu führt dass
das ganze System
wirklich in eine Schieflage kommt oder
dass man dann sehr schnell
wiederherstellen kann das ist
insbesondere bei den Datenkabeln auch
durchaus sagen mal schon Realität also
es ist jetzt nicht so dass wenn ein
Datenkabel
gekappt wird dass dann das Internet
zusammenbricht dafür ist das Internet ja
auch extra gebaut worden quasi diese
unterschiedlichen Wege gehen zu können
und dann werden die Datenpakete eben
umgeleitet und da kann man eben dann
nachlegen zu sagen also wenn wir eben
gewisse Knotenpunkte haben wo sehr viel
zusammen läuft und wo es se verwundbar
ist natürlich diese schützen aber eben
auch noch für mehr Verbindung sorgen
dass es dann eben einfach auf breiterer
Basis steht dann bei anderen Themen wie
z.B der Energieversorgung da ist es eben
dann sehr eng also gerade auch nach dem
Anschlag ist es so dass natürlich das
verbleibende Erdgas was nach Deutschland
kommt durch noch weniger Kanäle läuft
oder bzw dann über Schiffe kommt und
dann muss man eben gucken dass man sich
auf diese neue Versorgung einstellt und
jetzt die Versorgung Richtung Norwegen
und da die Pipelines besonders intensiv
schützt und ich glaube das wird auch
jetzt zur Zeit schon gemacht das kann
man natürlich nie ausschließen dass
nicht doch noch was passiert aber da
priorisiert man sicherlich und zu guter
Letzt ist es natürlich auch noch sagen
wir mal die die Frage
wir sagen mal können auch auf Land
natürlich nicht alles schützen wir
müssen einfach in grundlegendes
Regelwerk schaffen dass alle
Infrastrukturbetreiber alle Privatfirmen
hinreichen investieren und es einfach
weniger wahrscheinlich machen dass
solche Dinge passieren dass auch
Mitarbeiter durch auch immer überprüft
werden dass einfach ein allgemeines
Problem Bewusstsein da ist und insofern
hoffen wir halt dass damit solche
wirklich schwer wiegenden und echt sag
mal kaum zu bewältigen Anschläge dann
einfach nicht mehr auf der Tagesordnung
sind aber ausschließend kann man es
natürlich letztlich nicht sie sprechen
in ihrer Studie ja auch von der Rolle
Russlands und Chinas auf kritische
Infrastruktur in internationalen
Gewässern welchen Einfluss haben diese
Länder konkret das ist ja
unterschiedlich also wir haben ja auch
gehört wir können jetzt auch nicht sagen
russland hat dieses oder jenes getan es
gibt verschiedene Hinweise auch gerade
vor den Anschlägen auf nordstream dass
Russland viele Aktivitäten zur
Kartierung von Untersee Infrastrukturen
macht und da versucht man eben durch
Präsenz das abzuschrecken
wir haben uns aber auch sonst natürlich
von Russland jetzt entkoppelt in Sachen
Erdgas zumindest in Sachen Pipelines mit
den Schiffen noch nicht und da würde man
eben weitergehen in dem Sinne dass wir
eben da nicht mehr verwundbar sind bei
China ist es natürlich was anderes wir
haben auch die Debatte ja z.B bei den
mobilfunklasten dass man darüber spricht
welche Technik darf da verbaut werden
und bei China im Bereich Maritim ist
besonders wichtig die Frage der
Investition in Häfen also vielleicht
erinnern sich ja einige Zuschauer an die
Debatte zum Hamburger Hafen wo die
Chinesen eingestiegen sind wo ja auch
sehr kontrovers diskutiert wurde
letztlich hat die Bundesregierung in
gewissen Anteil erlaubt aber da ist eben
immer mehr kritische Aufmerksamkeit dass
man sagt wir können es nicht erlauben
dass die Chinesen diese kritische
Infrastruktur anderer Art zu sehr
aufkaufen zu sehr dominieren wie das z.B
in Griechenland schon der Fall ist und
da müssen wir einfach durch langfristige
strategische Wirtschafts und
investitionsp Politik dagegen halten sie
haben das eben schon angedeutet das eine
ist ja die Frage wie staten besser
zusammenarbeiten und das andere ist die
Frage ob nicht auch Betreiber von
kritischer
Infrastruktur mehr zum Schutz
unternehmen müssen ja also natürlich ist
einmal so Sicherheit erstmal ein sag mal
Verlustgeschäft für jegliches
Unternehmen das ist eine Frage der
Regulierung die kommt durch Europa und
jetzt dieses Jahr auch verstärkt noch
mal in Deutschland durch daskretes
dachgesetz es werden auch andere
Strategien zusätzlich aufgelegt eine
hafenstrategie also da ist einiges in
der Pipeline letztlich muss man
natürlich immer noch sehen wie viel Geld
ist dann am Ende da auch an Zuschüssen
m aber die Betreiber großer und
wichtiger Infrastrukturen kommen um
diese Verpflichtung sicherlich nicht
herum das andere ist noch mal was ich ja
gerade angedeutet habe gibt es auch eine
wirklich gemeinsame deutsche europäische
Investitionsstrategie und und
investitionsidee auch in anderen Ländern
nicht nur in Europa z.B auch in Afrika
oder global gesehen auf Infrastrukturen
das muss natürlich öffentlich gefördert
werden da können dann Partnerschaften
entstehen zwischen privaten und
staatlichen Akteuren das ist auch
gewollt im sogenannten global Gateway
der EU aber das kann nicht alleine durch
privatwirtschaftliche Akteure übernommen
werden denken wir jetzt vielleicht noch
mal an die Frachtschiffe die aktuell
immer wieder von huthi Milizen
überfallen werden das wäre ein anderes
Beispiel ähm wer müsste da reagieren um
diese Angriffe abzuwehren was passiert
da aktuell die EU hat jetzt gerade sich
auf den Weg gemacht
da eine neue Mission zu starten um diese
Schiffe zu eskortieren und auf Angriffe
zu reagieren die USA und die
Großbritannien haben auch ihrerseits
schon militärisch agiert auch mit
Beteiligung einiger europäischer Staaten
aber nicht mit Deutschland Deutschland
ist nur in diesem Rahmen der
europäischen Mission zur Eskorte und
nicht sagen mal zum aktiven Angriff auf
die Stellung von houtis dabei und das
ist auch erstmal nicht ganz
grundsätzlich neu wir hatten auch schon
vorherige Mission gegen Piraterie in der
Zone und insofern hoffen wir dass das
ausreicht um dann einen einigermaßen
reibungslosen Schiffsverkehr zu
gewährleisten zusätzlich gibt's
natürlich immer noch Fragen der
Versicherungen aber gerade bei solchen
Gewaltkonflikten fallen dann meistens
die Versicherungen aus und m jetzt
zeitweise hatten wir ein große Umlenkung
über das Horn von Afrika ganz unten was
sehr kostenintensiv ist also im Prinzip
ist es jetzt erstmal eine militärische
Eskorte und Abschreckung W wird sehen ob
es ausreicht leider ist natürlich die
regionale Lage noch schwieriger als in
vorherigen Jahren also einmal Piraterie
bekämpfen ist eines wenn aber jetzt Iran
und die ganze Region quasi im Konflikt
liegt dann ist es noch mal was anderes
und dann reicht es vielleicht auch nicht
aus geh wir noch mal gedanklich nach
Europa zurück letzte Frage an Sie gehen
Sie davon aus dass europäische kritische
infrastr Struktur auch in Zukunft das
Ziel von Attacken verstärkt sein wird
also grundsätzlich ist krittis immer
schon Ziel gerade auch im cyberbereich
das ist ein teigliches Geschäft wir
hatten aber auch die Angriffe wo auf die
Bahn verschiedenlich also dann
Datenkabel gekappt worden sind und so
weiter also darauf muss man sich
wirklich einstellen die Frage ist wie
schwerwiegend wie disruptiv sind dann
diese Angriffe ich sehe jetzt noch nicht
dass wirklich Russland mit Kraft
europäische Infrastruktur angreift das
ist in der Ukraine der Fall wir hatten
gerade heute wieder Luftangriffe und
auch Angriffe aufs gasnetzwerk in der
Ukraine aber in Europa
ist es nach aktuellen Stand jetzt nicht
dass wir mit derartter
intensiver Kampagne rechnen müssen aber
wir müssen gewappnet sein und auch schon
natürliche Störung von Infrastrukturen
können ebenso wichtig sein also wir
müssen in diese Resilienz wie ich gesagt
habe also diese redundanten Strukturen
plus allgemeine sicherheitsvorkehr
investieren denn langfristig ist das
sicherlich das Geld wert Herr B ich
danke Ihnen für das Gespräch und wünsche
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend tschüss
schönen Abend ja soweit ZDF heute live
zu den neuesten Entwicklungen im
nordstream Fall vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen für eure Fragen und Kommentare
bis bald macht's gut
tschüss
[Musik]